microphone check one two one two one two
one two one two one two gravity you got
it
microphone check one two one two one two
one two one two
microphone check one two one two
one two three four five might check one
two one two one two one two this one
from the front one two one two
got it thank you it's for the one
o'clock
all right
so
uh
yeah all right
real
yeah
um
what
two-minute warning on the briefing
two-minute warning on the briefing
thank you
two minutes
okay
so
uh
you
okay
i have to give you a fancy introduction
uh
good afternoon um president biden is
continuing to follow through on his key
promise to take
swift and bold action that addresses the
climate crisis
building on his day one actions of
rejoining the paris agreement
and strengthening our clean air and
water protections and
to and holding polluters accountable
today he will take executive action to
tackle the climate
climate crisis at home and abroad while
creating good
paying union jobs building sustainable
infrastructure
and delivering environmental justice
i'm thrilled today as a part of our
effort to bring policy experts
into the briefing room we're joined by
two very special guests who are going to
take
take you talk to you all about today's
executive orders
and take a few questions as well and i
will always as always play the role of
bad cop when they have to go
uh national climate advisor gina
mccarthy uh and special presidential
envoy for climate
and my former boss former secretary of
state john kerry and a big day for
boston in the briefing room so
okay thank you
it's a big day for boston every day
thank you everybody
today president biden will build on the
actions he took
on day one and he'll take more steps
to fulfill commitments he made
to tackle the climate crisis while
creating good
paying union jobs and achieving
environmental justice in his campaign
he and vice president harris put forward
the most ambitious climate vision
that any presidential ticket had ever
embraced
and he spent more time campaigning on
climate than we have
ever seen the president also has
consistently
identified the climate crisis as one of
four
interrelated existential crises that are
gripping our nation
all at once and he's demanding answers
that can address
all four and he's not waiting to take
action getting us started
on his first day in office because
science
is telling us that we don't have a
moment to lose to fight
against all four of these crises in a
way that recognizes their
intersectionality
he's always committed the u.s to reenter
i'm sorry he's already committed
the us to re-enter the paris climate
agreement
and he committed us as well to start
undoing the assault
on our environment that has occurred
over the past four years
and he is now taking additional action
to really target the challenge of
climate change
so today for me is a very good day just
one week into this administration
president biden is continuing
to move us forward at the breath and the
pace
that climate science demands today's
executive order starts
by saying it is the policy of this
administration that climate
considerations
shall be an essential element of u.s
foreign policy and national security
that's where the big guy comes in it
gives my colleague
john kerry the first ever international
climate envoy
the authority to really drive forward a
process
that will restore american leadership on
climate throughout the world
and you will see and hear more about
that from secretary kerry
but here at home we have to do our part
or we will not be
able to make the kind of worldwide
change
that climate change demands so this
executive order establishes a white
house
office of domestic climate policy and it
directs everyone
who works for the president to use every
tool
available at our disposal to solve the
climate crisis
because we're going to take a whole of
government
approach we're going to power our
economy
with clean energy we're going to do that
in a way that will produce
millions of american jobs that are going
to be
good paying that are going to be jobs
that have opportunity
for workers to join a union because as
president biden has often told us
when he thinks of climate change his
first thought is about
jobs and it should be because people in
this country
need a job and this is about making that
happen
in the most creative and significant way
that the federal government can move
forward
and we're going to make sure that nobody
is left behind and i'm not just talking
about communities
in terms of environmental justice but
workers as well
this order takes historic strides to
address environmental injustice
it creates both a white house
interagency
task force to address environmental
justice as well as an
advisory council it directs the
department of health and human services
to create an
office of climate change and health
equity because after all climate change
is the most significant
public health challenge of our time and
it tasks the department of justice
with establishing an office of climate
justice
because we know the communities who are
being hurt and we know we have to start
enforcing the standards today
and ensuring that they are part of the
solution
in the places that we can invest in fact
it commits 40 percent
of our investment in clean energy
towards disadvantaged communities so
they can
benefit from the new jobs that are
available and seed that better future
president biden's order establishes a
working group on coal and power plant
communities
because we have to make sure that in
this transition
every agency in government is using
every tool at their disposal to drive
resources
to those communities and it fulfills
long-standing commitments to leverage
our vast natural resources to contribute
to our clean energy future it places
a pause and review on new oil and gas
leases on federal public lands
and waters consistent with a promise
president biden has repeatedly made and
has been very clear
in the face of efforts to distort his
promise
and it sets a goal of doubling offshore
wind production by 2030.
in addition he plans to sign a
presidential memorandum
that aims to restore scientific
integrity across the federal government
and earn back the public's trust making
a commitment to base solutions
on the best available science and data
so today is a very big day for science
and for our efforts to power our economy
with good paying union jobs thank you
very much
good afternoon everybody it's great to
be here uh let me say first of all
uh what a pleasure it is to be here with
gina
uh i'm a big fan of gina's gina and i
work very very closely together
during the campaign uh when we sat down
to
uh bring the bernie sanders folks uh
together around the biden
climate plan and and she is the perfect
person to be tackling
uh the domestic side of this
equation which is complicated and nobody
knows the details better than she does
and nobody's going to be more effective
at corralling
everybody to move in the same direction
it's also an enormous pleasure for me to
be here with jen
saki she mentioned that nobody was her
boss but i
had the privilege of working with her
and she
uh seven years ago we
gathered in the state department
briefing room she's traded up
obviously but she has not uh
given away any of her fundamental
principles and commitment to
telling you all the truth telling the
american people the truth and doing so
with great candor
and transparency and i'm very happy to
be here with her
the stakes the stakes on climate change
just simply couldn't be
any higher than they are right now uh it
is existential we use that word too
easily
we throw it away but we have a big
agenda in front of us on a global basis
and president biden is deeply committed
totally seized by this issue as you can
tell by this executive order
and and by the other uh the initiative
getting back into paris immediately
that's why he rejoined the paris
agreement so quickly
because he knows it is urgent he also
knows
that paris alone is not enough
not when almost 90 percent of all of the
planet's emissions
global emissions come from outside of
u.s borders
we could go to zero tomorrow and the
problem isn't solved
so that's why today one week into the
job president biden
will sign this additional executive set
of orders
to help move us down the road ensuring
that ambitious climate action
is global in scope and scale
as well as national here at home
today in the order that he will sign
that gina is described to you
he makes climate central to foreign
policy planning
to diplomacy and to national security
preparedness
it creates new platforms to coordinate
climate action across the federal
agencies and departments sorely needed
and most importantly it commissions
a national intelligence estimate on the
security implications of climate change
to give
all of us an even deeper understanding
of the challenge this is the first time
a president has ever done that
and our 17 intelligence agencies are
going to come together
and assess exactly what the danger and
damage and potential
risks are the order directs the state
department to prepare
transmittal package seeking senate
advice and consent
on the kigali amendment to the montreal
protocol
an amendment that by itself if if
ratified and fully enforced globally
could hold the earth's temperature by
0.5 of an entire degree
not insignificant and it sets forth a
process for us to develop an ambitious
new paris target as well as a u.s
climate finance plan both of which are
essential to our being able to bring
countries of the world
together to raise ambition and meet this
moment
when we go to glasgow for the follow-on
agreement to paris
so that's the only way for the world to
succeed together my friends is uh
again this is an issue where failure
literally is not an option
as he committed to doing on the campaign
trail
the president is announcing that he will
host a leaders summit
on climate change less than three months
from now
on april 22nd earth day which will
include a leader
level reconvening of the major economies
forum
we'll have specifics to lay out over
time
uh but uh the convening of this
uh of this summit is essential to
ensuring
that the that 2021 is going to be the
year that really makes up for the lost
time of the last four years
and that the u.n climate conference cop
26 as it's called
which the uk is hosting in november uh
to make sure that it is an unqualified
success
the road to glasgow will be marked
uh not just by promises but by progress
at a pace that we can all be proud of
and gina is going to be putting her
efforts into making certain that that is
true the world will measure us by what
we can do
here at home so with these executive
actions today
uh we believe we're steps further down
that journey
thank you all right uh
let's start with nancy thank you so much
uh
secretary kerry question for you and
then for administrator mccarthy
um you talked about the fact that it
won't really matter
what we do very much if the rest of the
world doesn't do the same thing but the
us has had a fairly rocky relationship
with china recently how do you plan to
try to bring both china and india to the
table on this issue
well before i before i answer that let
me just say that uh
the issue of uh
of of making a difference i.e what we do
at home
what i'm saying is you can't solve the
problem alone but
our doing things makes an enormous
difference what gina succeeds in pulling
together
is essential to our ability to have
credibility in the world
now with respect to china obviously we
have
serious differences with china and some
very very important issues
and i am as mindful of that as anybody
having uh
served as secretary of state and in the
senate
uh the issues of theft of uh
intellectual property and and uh access
to market
south china sea i mean run the list we
all know them
those issues will never be traded for
anything
that has to do with climate that's not
going to happen but climate
is a critical standalone issue that we
have to deal on
uh in in the sense that uh china is 30
of the emissions of the world we're
about 15 of the emissions of the world
you add the eu to that
and you've got three entities that are
more than
than uh 55 or so
so it's urgent that we find a way to
compartmentalize to move forward
and uh we'll wait and see but uh
president biden is very very clear
about the need to address the other
issues with china
and i know some people have been
concerned nothing is going to be
siphoned off into one area from another
then a question for
either of you on coal your executive
order talks about
oil and gas on federal lands but it
doesn't really say much about coal what
is this administration's policy when it
comes to coal
well in terms of the oil and gas
decision it was is to make sure that we
take a little pause and review
the entire strategy of how we're looking
at public lands
so it will include looking at at what
new leases
ought to be approved and sold it's
looking at our ability
also to look at coal in that mix so the
program review is going to look at how
we manage public lands consistent with
climate
but also consistent with the marriage
between climate and really growing jobs
of the future
so it will be in the mix to be looked at
but it is it is not
at this point included it was not part
of the commitments on the campaign
but we're going to take a close look at
all of it and can i just add on your
your comment about china which i'm not
going to speak to the international
dynamic but i am going to say that part
of the challenge that we face here
is is a challenge that president biden
has already started to address with his
buy america pledge
we have to start not just go shifting to
clean energy
but it has to be manufactured in the
united states of america
you know not in other countries and
there is going to be
a large discussion about how we make
sure that a lot of the investment is
is about building up our manufacturing
base again
that's great jobs that's often hopefully
union jobs
but it is also a wonderful opportunity
for us to recoup the benefits
of that manufacturing and lower the cost
of clean energy
part of the way we're going to get there
is by making sure the federal government
buys american and that the federal
government looks at its procurement
across every agency
so that the breadth of what we spend is
spent
designed to advance job growth in the
united states
to advance health benefits for
environmental justice communities
and to begin to tackle the very
challenge the existential challenge of
climate change
jeff mason uh thank you jeff mason with
reuters
question for both of you can you give us
a sense of
when you expect to have the so-called
ndc or u.s
target for cutting greenhouse gas
emissions as part of the pair support
and can you also give us a sense of how
ambitious you plan to make that number
will it be
40 50 higher than that
yeah i'm the dude who's supposed to
deliver this in a timely way and he sets
the timing
so that uh basically we want to make
sure that the
ndc is something that can be announced
before the summit
on earth day and so we're going to be
out of the gate working with the
agencies to see
what kind of reductions and mitigation
opportunities there are
and also again to look at our public
lands to make sure that we can continue
to store carbon in our soil
to work with agriculture and others to
look at how we better manage our forests
so we're not
uh seeing the devastating forest fires
that we've been having before
so all across the federal government
every agency
and you'll see many of them specifically
tasked in this
executive order we'll participate in the
task force that we're going to have
to actually develop the most aggressive
ndc that we can
to deliver the kind of boost
that secretary kerry is looking for to
be able to ensure that our international
efforts
are robust and insufficient to address
the
challenge internationally follow up on
that perhaps for secretary kerry
how do you assure international partners
that the u.s will stick to whatever you
propose
after having seen the trump
administration take
the us out of the paris accord well
that's precisely why we're going to
stick by it and i think our word is
strong i've been on the phone for the
last few days
talking to our allies in europe
elsewhere around the world
uh and they are welcoming us back they
know
that this administration uh already had
a significant
part of what has brought us to will
bring us to glasgow which was the paris
agreement
the obama biden administration
had great credibility on this issue and
having president biden be the person now
who is driving this forward
is enormously meaningful to to to the
folks there and they also know that i
was
deeply involved in the negotiations in
paris
and am now asked by the president by
president biden
to make certain that we do the same in
classical if not more
so i have had no one question our
credibility
at this point in time uh someone
probably will
and the answer will be that that i think
we can achieve
things in the course of the next four
years that will
move the marketplace the private sector
uh global finance uh innovation and
research
that in fact no no one no political
person in the future would be able to
undo
what the planet is going to be
organizing over these next months and
years
this is the start of something new i
know if you read
larry fink's letter of blackrock the
other day yesterday
but there's a new new awareness among
major
asset managers commercial banks and
others
about the need to be putting resources
into this endeavor
because it it is it is major in in
investment uh
demand so i i think uh
the the proof will be in what we do
neither gina nor i are going to start
you know throwing around a lot of big
promises but you heard what she just
said and we will work
very closely because we're going to try
to bring to the table to help
uh inform her and the folks he's working
with
what we're picking up abroad and what
people are doing abroad and
the steps that they're taking and how we
now have to measure ourselves against
them and they will measure themselves
against us
we are well aware of that
i just want to call attention to the
fact that cities and states
have really picked up the the initiative
to move forward on clean energy
because the solutions are cheap
the solutions compete effectively
against fossil fuels
we are talking about solutions that
we're not asking anybody to sacrifice
but
are to their advantage and if you look
at the record over the past four
years while the prior administration
might have wanted energy clean energy to
head in a different direction
it's gone faster and farther than anyone
ever expected
and the idea that we could with this new
work that we're doing
together send signals to the marketplace
who are purchasing at the federal level
and are we looking at different ways of
having on the ground change
we can build that demand we can actually
grow
significantly millions of clean energy
jobs
and all of a sudden the question won't
be whether the private sector is going
to buy into it
the private sector is going to drive it
and so this
is going to be a signal setter the way
the federal government ought to set
on what our values are what we think the
future needs to be
and that's it's this is a value-lading
at laden effort
that president biden has undertaken with
full
knowledge that it's going to benefit
jobs it's going to benefit our health
and it's going to lead to that future we
want to hand to our children we'll just
do these
two in the front and then they will come
back i promise um
so thank you mr secretary if you would
um
there certainly are oil and gas industry
workers who are watching
you both right now who will hear the
message
that's that the takeaway to them is that
they are seeing an end to their
livelihoods
uh what what do you say to them
particularly those people
who who president trump struck a chord
with on the campaign trail when he
promised to
save their jobs what is your message to
them right now and also to the oil
industry executives who are listening
are you putting them on notice today
well we didn't come here to put
anybody on notice except to the
seriousness of president
biden's intent to do what needs to be
done to deal with this crisis
and it is a crisis um
with respect to those workers no
no two people are more uh in this room
are more concerned about it and the
president of the united states
has expressed in every comment he has
made about
climate the need to
uh grow the new jobs that pay better
that are cleaner than i mean
you know you look at the consequences of
black lung for a minor for instance and
measure that against the fastest growing
job in the united states before covet
was solar power technician the same
people can do those jobs
but the choice of doing the solar power
one now is a better choice
similarly uh you have uh the second
fastest growing job pre-coped
was wind turbine technician this is
happening
75 70 of all the electricity that's come
online in the united states in the last
few years
came from renewables not
you know coal plants have been closing
over the last
20 years so what president
biden wants to do is make sure those
folks
have better choices that they have
alternatives that they can be the people
who go to work
to make the solar panels they were
making them here at home
that is going to be a particular focus
of the uh
buildback better agenda and and i
i think that that unfortunately workers
have been fed a false narrative no
surprise
right for the last few years they've
been fed
uh the notion that somehow dealing with
climate
is coming at their expense no it's not
what's happening to them is happening
because of other market forces already
taking place
and and and what the what the what the
financiers
the big banks the asset managers private
investors
venture capital are all discovering is
there's a lot of money to be made in the
creation of these new jobs
in these sectors so whether it's green
hydrogen
that is going to come whether it is a
geothermal heat or whether it whatever
it's going to be
uh those are jobs the same worker who
works in south carolina today putting
together
a bmw which happens to be made there and
and and is currently an internal
combustion engine can put together a car
but it's electric so this is not a
choice between
having jobs having good jobs having the
quality of life
quality of life will be better when gina
has put
her team together that produces choices
for us
that are healthier less cancer cleaner
air the greatest the greatest cost of
america the greatest cause of children
being hospitalized every summer in the
united states
we spend 55 billion a year on it is
environmentally induced asthma that will
change
as we begin to rein in what we used to
call pollution in this country
because it is pollution and i think that
workers are going to see
that with the efforts of the biden
administration
they're going to have much better set of
choices and frankly
it will create more jobs than stuck
where we were
could i just add by pointing out a
couple of things in the executive order
that i want you to
just call to your attention we talked
about the civilian conservation corps
that is an opportunity to put younger
people into work
and and vitally important efforts but if
you look at this it also
has set up a task force that is looking
at the
these coal uh communities communities
that are really reliant on their local
energy and utility
and it talks about how do we revitalize
those economies
and it talks about how we can put people
to work
using the skills they currently have
where they are
to start looking at those old abandoned
oil and gas
wells that are spewing out methane or
all of the coal that that is mines
that haven't been properly closed that
are doing the same
that has great impact on climate but
also will keep
an opportunity for those for those
individual workers
to have work in their own communities
we're not going to ask people to go from
the middle of ohio or or
or pennsylvania and ship out to the
coast to have
solar jobs you know solar jobs will be
everywhere but we need to put people to
work in their own communities that's
where their home is
that's where the vision is so we're
creatively looking at those
opportunities for investment
so that we can get people understanding
that we are not trying
to take away jobs remember when when we
say climate change
eventually people are going to think
jobs just like president biden
when he hears the words climate change
and so we'll do everything we can to
recognize that revitalization is
necessary in these communities
to find creative ways to put them to
work and then we're going to do as
secretary kerry says
and start investing in new technologies
and new manufacturing
and that includes the large
manufacturing like cement
and steel that's work that we should be
doing here
that's work that inevitably is going to
be necessary
to rebuild our infrastructure which is
also one of the biggest
opportunities we have for job growth
moving forward two quick questions
sure uh administrator one to you and one
of the secretary if i may
what you may hear from some corridors of
criticism is why
are we doing this now when we're already
in an economic crisis you look at
the state of new mexico where one-third
of the state's budget is funded by
oil and gas so why not let the country
get back
on its feet before we do this well
the issue in new mexico is that somebody
reported a bid incorrectly or maybe not
as precisely enough
that this wasn't about impacting
existing permits and fracking
this was about new leases on federal
lands
so i think that the the opportunity for
the states to continue
to accrue the royalties and from from
uh from both coal and oil and natural
gas that is
properly done on federal lands is going
to continue
and there's even an opportunity in the
review of that program
to look at the royalty issues look at
the job growth opportunities look at a
variety of things to make sure
that public lands are being properly
managed now in terms of the job issue
we're explicitly doing this because
our economy is right now stagnant
we have millions of people out of work
out of jobs millions of people
that are afraid they can't feed their
families if you're faced with that what
do you do
you boost the economy and you grow jobs
but why
at the same time aren't we thinking
about the weaknesses of our current
economy
in terms of the number of environmental
justice communities that have been left
behind
the number of people that are breathing
dirty air
and their kids are getting asthma so
instead let's think about all of it at
the same time i know it's a crazy idea
in your bureaucracy
you're only supposed to do one thing
we're going to do and think about all of
it
because people need to have jobs this is
all about building the jobs of the
future we want
not continuing to niddle at at an
economy that is no longer going to be
where our future lies
mr secretary to you right now over the
course of this first week
there are a lot of big priorities here
there's coven the economy
immigration racial justice now climate
change is a veteran
of congress of the senate what is the
priority and how quickly do you need
legislation
to make this permanent well the
peter the the uh
the priority is precisely what the
president has set out
all of them all six of the major crises
that he faces
and he's addressing every single one of
them and he knows that the united states
all of us have the ability to be able to
do that uh
and and the reason that has to be done
is every single one of them are life and
death every single one of them
represent a challenge the very fiber of
our society
and and the other reason obviously
everything i agree with everything gina
said
but i'd simply add that the other reason
for doing it now is the science
tells us we have to and that's one of
the things the president is restoring
today
in the executive order is respect for
science and the science office
so i i mean uh two trillion dollar price
tag
two trillion dollars for kova two
trillion for this is a lot of money to a
lot of americans
it is real money and yes it's a lot of
money but you know what it costs a lot
more if you don't
do the things we need to do it costs a
lot more
there are countless economic analyses
now that show
that it is now cheaper to deal with the
crisis of climate
than it is to ignore it we spent 265
billion dollars two years ago on three
three storms irma harvey and maria
maria destroyed puerto rico harvey
dropped more water on houston in five
days and goes over niagara falls in a
year
and irma had the first recorded winds at
185 miles an hour for 24
sustained hours that last year with one
storm
55 billion dollars so we're spending the
money folks
we're just not doing it smart we're not
doing it in the way that would actually
sustain us for the long term
so this is uh critical we're
the goal of the paris agreement was to
hold the earth's temperature increase to
two degrees centigrade
even if you did everything that was in
paris we're going up 3.7 or 4.
that's catastrophic what president biden
is trying to do is listen to science
listen to facts and make tough decisions
about what we need to do to take the
world to a better place and particularly
our own country
and that is what he is committed doing
so yes there are a lot of
challenges right now which sadly all of
them
were exacerbated by the last four years
now we have to try to make up for that
and that is a hard pull but this
president is capable of doing it he's
putting together a great team that i
think can
help him do that thank you sir thank you
thank you
thank you uh gina mccarthy thank you
secretary kerry for joining us
um you're free to go thank you to go see
the president
um so you can all see they're uh both
experienced and passionate and tenacious
uh having worked with uh
with both of them in the past so uh the
the
crisis is in good hands i know we have a
short period of time here but i just
wanted to provide an update on a
question that
you all have been asking a bit about
which is what some of the outreach
uh our teams are doing as it relates to
the coveted package that is a top
priority for
president biden as we have talked about
almost every day in here probably every
day
our team continues to build support for
the american rescue plan
as more and more voices across the
country recognize the urgent need to get
american families
the help they need we've obviously seen
a broad coalition of support emerge
from the chamber of commerce to senator
sanders in organized labor to hundreds
of mayors and local public
health officials the president vice
president are engaged directly
with members and have had a number of
productive conversations
that will continue through the course of
the week and will only pick up in the
days ahead
senior white house officials are also
engaging with not just congressional
leaders but also state and local
officials
key constituency groups and others to
gather feedback on the proposal and move
the package forward
so let me give you a couple of examples
from uh just
yesterday chief of staff ron klein
engaged with members directly throughout
the day as did senior adviser anita dunn
which they will both continue to do
moving forward
counselor to the president steve
roshetti and office of legislative
affairs director louisa terrell are
quarterbacking the team's broader
legislative outreach
and have had dozens of conversations
with individual members to understand
their priorities and receive their
feedback
in addition to ongoing conversations
with leadership on both sides of the
aisle
already this week members of the
national economic council and domestic
policy council
and staff from treasury have met with
the relevant committees including senate
banking committee senate finance
committee house ways and means
house financial services house education
and labor
and the bicameral small business
committee nec director brian diese is
doing one-on-one briefings with members
of congress
and meetings with caucuses including
yesterday's meeting
which i believe has been reported with
the problem solvers caucus to discuss
the proposal
hill engagement will continue with jeff
zions and brandise meeting with the new
dem coalition
along with several other briefings that
are scheduled
also our outreach isn't limited to
congress which is vitally important this
isn't just about speaking to elected
officials this is also about speaking to
the country and building support
and uh educating and engaging with
leaders
across the country so yesterday jeff
science and his team spoke with
bipartisan governors as you all know
they talked about the coveted package
by the national governors association
organized by them and administration
officials briefed tribal leaders and
number of mayors yesterday as well
and the office of public engagement led
by cedric richmond briefed civil rights
groups yesterday including the naacp
the national action network justice
action network urban league coalition of
black civic participation
and black women's roundtable today they
have meetings with labor leaders
advocates for young
people as well as organizations
dedicated to building wealth
in the black community on friday op will
also the office of public engagement i
should say i hate acronyms
we'll convene a hundred presidents of
historically
black colleges and universities also to
discuss this proposal
and the only other thing i wanted to
mention before we get to your questions
is that
as you all know treasury secretary janet
yellen just confirmed
the president will be meeting with
economic team on friday including
secretary yellen
for briefing on the impact of delay and
moving forward with the additional
economic relief with that let's get your
questions alex your first day in the
white house briefing room
and alex's first day two alex's first
days it's good to be here there's an
initiation afterwards
because the press corps will head out
yes go ahead
um i'll make it quick because i know you
have a pretty heart out in a few minutes
but
i think you all have a heart out too but
yes um
i wanted to ask about one of your
favorite topics impeachment
nearly every republican senator last
night voted to throw out the impeachment
trial against president trump
does president biden have a reaction to
that does he trust
congress to hold president trump
accountable for the
insurrection against the capital and
does he see censure against
former president trump as a viable
alternative to conviction since it looks
unlikely at this point
well the uh president certainly respects
the role that congress has
senators of course the senate as they're
overseeing the trial moving forward
in determining the pace and the path
forward uh
for holding the former president
accountable that continues to be his
belief
in all of his conversations that he's
been having with members about
the recovery plan he has they have
said they expect from him that his focus
will be on coveted relief
that's how he will use the bully pulpit
that's how he will speak to the american
people
and they are eager to work with him on
that so that's where his focus remains
and and what steps they take to hold the
former president accountable uh he'll
leave it to them why the resistance on
weighing in on the issue
we've weighed in many times the
president has been asked about the issue
we put out a statement when the house
put out a vote
voted on impeachment i should say but
his focus
is on doing delivering on what the
american people elected him to do which
is to
get relief to the to the american people
to get the pandemic under control
to ensure working families can put food
on the table and that's where he feels
his efforts should be
should remain okay go ahead okay so does
the white house have a comment
on this social media profile that has
emerged of representative marjorie
taylor
green um and is there a response to
whether any disciplinary action should
be taken against or given everything
that's come out
we don't and i'm not going to speak
further about her
i think in this briefing room okay um go
ahead one more if you don't mind just
kind of a little bit of a housekeeping
sure the last administration had
suggested that uh on the origins of the
19 virus that it may have originated in
the lab in china
um it was never definitive do you have
an update
on that on the origin of where we are on
that investigation
uh well first um obviously the
um the misinformation of course that has
we've seen also come out of um
of uh some sources in china's is of
great concern to us
it's imperative that we get to the
bottom of the early days of the pandemic
in china and we've been
supportive of an international
investigation
that we feel should be robust and clear
uh we
our view is that we must prepare to draw
on information collected and analyzed by
our intelligence community which is
something that is ongoing
and to work and also to continue work
with our allies to evaluate
the report's credibility on the
investigation once it's done
in addition as you all know secretary of
state was just tony blinken was just
sworn in
yesterday and one of his priorities is
of course ensuring that
our staffing on the ground in beijing
which is something that
fell back in the last administration is
returned to what it was prior which
means we want to have
uh science uh experts policy experts on
the ground
in the roles that they should be serving
in uh to ensure that uh
you know we're also there representing
um you know our interests uh from the
united states on the ground in china
go ahead a couple quick ones that i
still don't think i fully understand i
know the executive order that was signed
but
has this white house invoked the dpa and
how soon till we'll actually see
companies
compelled to produce supplies or vaccine
or whatever else that impacts
americans uh we it was invoked um the
day it was signed within 24 hours of it
being signed
the process so i guess that meant it was
invoked yes and i confirmed that
uh when it was the next day the
following day in the briefing room which
i realized everybody can't be here every
day because of covid
um but uh it was invoked and it means
that our work is
ongoing uh with uh companies to ensure
that we are
expediting the manufacturing of
materials to ensure that we can get 100
million shots
in the arms of americans and i know
there's been some confusion about this
and what exactly it is what does the dpa
mean
uh there are a few examples that our
team has cited
including uh vex on vaccine supply low
dead space syringes
which means it allows for the ability to
get an extra dose into the pfizer vial
which is important to getting
more doses out there help additional n95
the production of additional n95 masks
isolation gowns uh gloves pipette tips
and high absorbency foam swabs
so we're really talking about very
specific materials that can be used by
vaccinators
to get these shots in the arms of
americans thanks for clarifying there
was some confusion on the earlier call
which is why i re
repeated here let me ask one other
question yesterday you deflected this to
the usoc but my questions
a little bit different today we're now
hearing from the organizers of this
year's summer games
in japan and the head of japan's
olympics committee is seeking public
reassurances
from president biden himself given that
the u.s of course is the largest
contingent of athletes that the game
should be able to go on
as the world's uh as the world is
dealing with pandemic right now based on
where we are
now with the vaccine does president
biden believe
the games in japan can safely go on
well the president and i'm not sure if
this readout had gone out yet but he had
spoken with
the prime minister of japan earlier this
morning and a readout was going out
as we were coming out to the briefing
i'm not sure if they spoke about the
olympics i'm happy to check with our
national security team on that
to follow up with but i don't have any
more assessment of the olympics uh at
this point in time
whether he is so it hasn't been
discussed whether he has a position on
whether it wouldn't safely be able to go
on yet
i i i don't have anything more other
than i haven't had much on it but i
don't have anything more than i've had
on other days on it so we asked so we'll
follow up
understood and they just had a call this
morning but i haven't had a chance to
talk to him specifically about it go
ahead
hey two vaccine questions first of all
this came up on the
cobit call earlier but how seriously
is the white house considering using the
defense production act to compel
other pharmaceutical companies to
produce the pfizer
and the dareda vaccines to do supply
well i didn't hear
the entirety of the call because we were
doing some preparation for the event
this afternoon
uh but from listening to our team talk
about it they're obviously manufacturing
uh facilities that have the capacity and
the ability to
get these vaccine doses um out and we
don't want to get our
get behind the pace of uh and start from
scratch i should say in
ensuring that they're ready to do that i
don't think our concern at this point
is whether or not we're going to have
the vaccine doses obviously
uh the president announced yesterday uh
the intention to purchase
additional doses the um our confidence
and
the manufacturers to have those doses
available
the concerns we have are uh one
contingency planning and all of the
different things that can happen
because this is a herculean task that
has never been done before
but also ensuring we have vaccinators we
have vaccine sites
etc available so i have not uh heard
from our team
plans to seek other manufacturers at
this point in time
and i'm happy to follow up with them and
see if there's anything additional
and then on the 200 million doses the
president said he's ordering them
what is the status of that order have
pfizer and mederna agreed
to produce 100 million doses each
and how quickly do they say they can do
it well
uh we expect to get the doses
by mid to late summer uh the the
majority of doses by mid to late summer
some earlier than that so
we're confident that we'll be able to
get those from the manufacturers yes
uh go ahead karen a couple questions on
schools does the administration plan to
develop metrics or standards for what a
safe reopening of schools will look like
we do and and our cdc director and i'm
not sure again if she was asked about
this important question
i know as a fellow mother um but we will
have um
uh specifics uh uh that will defer to
the
cdc on on the safe reopening of schools
as you know the president talked about
uh has talked about his commitment and
his goal of reopening most k-8
schools within 100 days there are
obviously a number of steps that will
need to be taken
in order for that to be possible but he
has directed the department of education
department of health and students and
human services to provide guidance on
safe reopening
and operating for schools child care
providers and institutions of higher
education but as our cova team has
outlined that's going to require
testing materials support for contact
tracing vaccinations for
teachers and ensuring they're equitably
provided but uh
our our cdc director and team will be uh
looking into putting together some
specific guidelines so there can be
clarity on that front which i know a lot
of districts are looking for those
things you mentioned all cost a lot of
money and a big part of the covid relief
package
is a lot of money to go to school
reopening if congress doesn't approve
the money you want and schools don't
have what they need
to pay for things to open safely would
the president support teachers staying
at home and support virtual learning
continuing through this entire school
year
well uh i think the president recognizes
as we all do
the value of having children in schools
and
doing that in a safe way which is one of
the reasons he set this ambitious goal
of reopening uh most k-8 schools within
100 days but one of the reasons that
this uh the funding for safe reopening
for
getting schools the equipment the
testing the
ventilation in some cases that they need
is because nobody wants to be having a
conversation in mayor june
about why schools are not reopened so
this goes back to the argument that our
team has been making and all of these
calls and engagements and meetings that
i
outlined about the importance and vital
nature of each component of the package
so we won't get into a hypothetical we
are confident that congress will
move forward with a package let me just
go we gotta wrap up soon okay i'm sorry
we'll do more questions tomorrow but we
have two such great guests um jen go
ahead thanks i just have two quick
questions
um one is just on the climate actions
today they leave out treasury's
financial stability oversight council
which
experts say could play an influential
role in addressing climate risk this is
the administration have
plans to take action on climate finance
and should exit direct agencies and
regulators to address climate change
well i'm going to use a reference that
my friend and colleague ambassador susan
rice used yesterday which is there are
453
days left in this administration and
addressing climate and the crisis of
climate
is uh an issue that the president has
conveyed to
members of his cabinet members of his
senior team is an absolute priority
so secretary yellen has been in in her
role for one day
but um certainly i'd send you to them
for any more specifics but this is the
beginning not the end of our work on
climate
nadia i'll go ahead um is the white
house concerned about the stock market
activity we're seeing around game stop
um and now with some other stocks as
well
uh including the subsidiary or whatever
the company that was uh blockbuster um
and have there been any conversations
with the
sec about how to proceed
well um i'm also happy to repeat that we
have the first female treasury secretary
and a team that's surrounding her and
often questions about market we'll send
to them but our team is of course our
economic team including
secretary yellen and others are
monitoring uh the situation it's a good
reminder though that the stock market
isn't the only measure of the health of
our econo
our economy doesn't reflect how working
and middle class families are doing
as you all know from covering this we're
in the midst of a case shape recovery
america's workers are struggling to make
ends meet which is why the president has
introduced
this urgent package to get immediate
relief to families
all right i'm going to go nadia and then
we'll be totally done because everybody
has to go okay okay
good to see you on a different podium i
have two questions
about china uh regarding kovid the
president promised to increase
supply to states by 10 million doses yet
statistics shows that 47 of americans
are hesitant
to take the vaccine despite that the
president vice president took it
publicly
what is the administration doing to
convince americans to take it
to reach the uh herd immunity by say 70
percent by the
by the fall you're absolutely right
nadia that this is one of the biggest
challenges we face and for anyone who
tuned into the briefing that
our health team led this morning it was
one of the first issues that cdc
director
uh dr wolenski raised and one of the
things we're doing
is prioritizing providing uh correct
information about it
uh and yeah the vaccines and one i'll
take the opportunity
uh the pfizer and modern vaccines are
safe and effective that's one of the
things she said today
they were tested in large clinical
trials to make sure they meet safety
standards
about 30 percent of u.s participants in
those trials were
hispanic african-american asian or
native american about half for older
adults
and so we want to provide clear data as
i just did but also we want to meet
people where they are
communicate directly with communities of
color people who have concerns
and use medical and health professionals
to do exactly that okay you had a china
question and then you really have to go
but go ahead
and second many welcome to your
rejoining of the who
yet some wants to push for a transparent
investigation into the relationship
between china
and who and also yesterday in her uh
hearing in the senate uh
governor ramon the decline uh to
blacklist
hawaii technology in the u.s is this
called some kind of
caving into china or is that a nuanced
uh
way to deal with china uh
so i think you're the second reference i
think was to huawei right and then come
yes um so let me just convey clearly our
position
on this um let us be clear
telecommunications equipment
made by untrusted vendors including
huawei is a threat to the security of
the us and our allies
we'll ensure that the american
telecommunications network do not use
equipment from untrusted vendors and
will work with allies to secure their
telecommunications networks
and make investments to expand the
production of telecommunications
equipment
by trusted u.s and allied companies
again we'll take many more questions
tomorrow thank you all
uh have a great rest of your day
you